there's a Drake what about the
allegations that your tests and killing
people you're finished well I think we
opened him up I have a reporter I found
something really bad
and I have been taken
cooperate and you just might survive why
would we do that
weren't you any problem
I used to me
I'm ad brought I'm a reporter I found
something really bad I heard a voice
I have been taking that what do you want
for me and you slide out
you have no idea how much you're scaring
me right now
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got some
new venom footage to break down we have
less than a month before the movie comes
out so we'll talk a little bit about how
the movie is laying Easter eggs for
carnage in my top 10 versions of the
symbiote even though there have been so
many people to get the symbiote in the
comics if you didn't read the edge of
the venom verse storyline this is an
entire universe where all the Marvel
characters are possessed by symbiotes
like I just posted that Captain Marvel
preview video Carol Danvers has had the
symbiote in the comics before so if
you're brand new to the channel there's
a new round of that spider-man ps4
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video uh name a new winner at the
end of this so this new footage just
lays more backstory about why Eddie
Brock is in disgrace you Eddie Brock
yeah used to be a little bit of a wink
at his comic book origin story but this
in the context of the movie he's in
disgrace as a reporter so he's looking
for a really hot scoop to reignite his
career and make everybody respect him
again when he hears about what Carlton
Drake is supposedly doing with inmates
from this prison here which is why they
have all these scenes at the prison very
important for Carnage's origin story
later on for those of you that remember
the comic book origin
what happened originally as as the Eddie
Brock gets locked up in prison after
spider-man takes him down while he's in
there the symbiote comes to bond with
him again so that he can become venom he
can escape while that was happening the
symbiote spawned offspring and because
the offspring had no emotional
attachment to Eddie Brock it bonded with
another nearby inmate Cletus Kasady
turning him into the Carters persona
they went on a rampage that eventually
built up to a climax in the maximum
carnage series where venom was forced to
team up with spider-man to take him down
the idea being that the prison itself is
a big easter egg it's important to the
plot of the early parts of the film
because Carlton Drake is essentially
taking all these inmates people that are
insane people that he thinks that no one
cares about or don't have family members
using them for all of his experiments
including the later ones once he
actually gets his hands on the symbiotes
and that Kraft spaceship the way they
set up Eddie is an antihero like not
your typical do-gooder
because he just has a bunch of shady
stuff in pursuit of breaking this story
but it's for a good cause because
Carlton Drake is killing all these
inmates that he thinks society has cast
out nobody cares about Eddie himself has
been cast out of society he feels like
an outsider so you kind of see what
they're doing there so is just a way to
get you to care about these early
symbiote tests remind you about the
prison from the comics for when they pay
off that carnage Easter Egg this sort of
introduce you to the idea of why Eddie
is the hero of this universe without
being a total white knight like say
spider-man Peter Parker but if you're
not a big comic book reader like I said
there been a bunch of crazy versions of
the symbiote some of them cooler than
others so this is my top 10 list number
10 Galactus venom the thing about this
is that even though it looks really cool
is that it was just a trick of
Mysterio's he created an illusion to
make it look like this
so the symbiote has never actually
possessed Galactus although that would
be an interesting theory to test given
how powerful he is number 9 x-23 in the
venom verse characters this was edge of
the venom verse or of an else world
story taking place in an alternate
universe where pretty much every Marvel
character you could imagine was
possessed by a symbiote fighting another
parasitic hive mind race that was trying
to assimilate all the heroes that had
been venom eyes to make itself more
powerful until they themselves figured
out that they could travel between the
multiverse and started to go off and
explore we're just a really interesting
twist on the idea and some of the
coolest comic book covers ever everybody
getting venom eyes for this which is so
badass so you just look at this even if
the story wasn't that great it was just
cool to look at number eight Flash
Thompson agent venom really interesting
spin on the venom character especially
given that he was a war hero they're
incorporating some aspects of his
character to the Eddie Brock of this
movie mostly in that he starts out as an
antihero number seven the Eddie Brock
ant even a really cool idea don't know
if they're ever actually gonna do it in
the movies but the whole idea is is that
long after the symbiote has gone on to
other hosts Eddie Brock gets cancer what
happens is his mr- comes to visit Eddie
Brock at a soup kitchen touches him and
through his power activates the latent
venom cells inside Eddie Brock's
bloodstream those bond with his cancer
cells turning him into anti-venom he
just has a bunch of powers that can
cleanse people of their symbiote sand
free them from their bond or if they
have infectious diseases it can clean
those up too so that's why it's called
the anti-venom like they treats venom
like a disease to be getting rid of six
red goblin which is the Green Goblin
bonded to the carnage symbiote crazy
idea that you know probably isn't gonna
last for very long but still really cool
twist so Norman Osborn had been taken
down by Peter Parker he had been
injected with nanites that prevented him
from activating the Goblin serum so that
he could not become green goblin anymore
so when the carnage symbiote bonded with
Norman Osborn the first thing he asked
it to do was get rid of the nanites in
his bloodstream so that he could become
Green Goblin the Goblin toxin interacted
with the carnage symbiote turning him
into the red goblin so it was just a way
for them to bring back Green Goblin into
the comics albeit with a really nuts
twist five even crazier but kind of cool
Red Hulk possessed by the spirit of
vengeance and wearing the Venom symbiote
at the same time this was during the
circle of four storyline so sort of this
team-up crossover of Red Hulk agent
venom x-23 in Ghost Rider against
Mephisto son black heart that was trying
to bring hell to earth during the battle
the spirit of vengeance has been
separated from Ghost Rider they're
trying to rebind them but ends up
binding to Red Hulk in Flash Thompson
gives Red Hulk his symbiote so he
becomes this crazy Hulk version of the
spirit of vengeance with the Venom
symbiote just absolutely nuts for the
cletus kasady carnage just a really cool
evolution of the idea of the Venom
symbiote like Venom's badass but let's
do something even crazier to make venom
seem like more of a hero so witty Brock
had been a villain for a long time in
the comics they just wanted to find
something new to do with the character
so this way you introduce somebody even
worse to give him a hero arc which is
why obviously the venom movie is
building up towards a carnage crossover
so you can have the uber hardcore
version of Eddie Brock that does a lot
of really shady stuff but he's
ultimately not the villain of the story
there's somebody even worse that's
coming three toxin which is actually the
offspring of the carnage symbiote even
more powerful even crazier but the whole
idea is is that carnage found out that
it existed came back to kill him off so
venom came to rescue it forming an
alliance between toxin and venom you
kind of see a theme picking up here
no matter which other symbiotes pop-up
carnage usually winds up being the
ultimate big bat of the symbiotes
universe number two the classic
spider-man Peter Parker wearing the
symbiote still hoped that we eventually
get a version of that inside either the
venom universe if not the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so maybe down the
road I think that the venom movie is
gonna find an alternate way to sort of
bind him to the spider-man mythos but
we'll see about that when the movie
comes out in number one of course my
favorite still is the eddie brock
classic Venom symbiote the original
still one of the best so when they
relaunched the venom comic book a little
while ago they sort of went back to
basics but they're trying to expand the
mythos by tying him to Thor through the
Grendel Beowulf tale I just did a video
about that I'll link it at the end of
this so as we get more footage for the
venom movie I'll try to explain more
Easter eggs and we'll get a better
picture for what it's going to be like
in the movie universe there was a new
scene from spider-man far from home that
dropped so I'll do a video for that that
should be up in a little while leave all
your spider-man venom video requests in
the comments below
cjp congratulations you're the giveaway
winner from my last big video please
email me on the about page of my youtube
channel click here for that Captain
Marvel a teaser video and click here for
that venom Thor video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]